as I understand you're sort of
discomfort correct me if I'm wrong I
think you have a discomfort with this
kind of placing of our own ownership of
every single choice and not being in
relationship with God with the others
but for my understanding of the Trinity
I sterling influenced by Jordan mold
none you know if you look at the Trinity
as persons in relation still emphasizing
the distinctiveness of each person in
relation I don't see such a strong
problem with emphasizing individual
choice rather I see the encouragement
and to be ideal as being one that is
always mutually choosing to the best for
the up i think i think it has more to do
with the transcending an objective
nature of human goods i mean it does
have to do with community but i i i i
can understand how how are theologically
one can still affirm rights as yoga more
and evident he does i haven't bed the
book but i know he has written on this
and an Trinitarian community the in the
the perspective which i'm putting
forward human freedom is the mode in
which we participate in the goods that
that God gives us whether these good to
be the human relationships of the divine
human relationship itself whether these
Goods be material or spiritual or relate
to the nonhuman creation and that when
one then attaches right to freedom one
is again I come back to the sort of miss
placement one is singling out the mode
of participation as something having a
kind of priority in a certain sense a a
an independent conceptual moral focus
and that I'm not willing to do and if I
did
it would probably be on on that point
are rather than then necessarily the
relational one but I do think that that
it the my point about juridical izing of
human relations that I think happens
with rights even when people are not
oriented too demanding their own lights
but that the demanding the rights of
their neighbors that still to me as a
theologian smacks of juridical icing of
human relationships and it's what the
the Reformers the both Protestant but
both some continental and English would
call works righteousness